una sonrisa en el rostro de faridd esta
foto publicada en Twitter fue tomada
pocos minutos después de su salida de
prisión el anuncio hecho el viernes por
sus familiares fue transmitido por las
autoridades francesas Francia celebra la
liberación de la señora faridá detenía
injustamente en Irán en la prisión de
Bin es esencial que la señora faridá
pueda recuperar todas sus libertades
incluido el derecho de regresar a
Francia hacia así lo desea
las condiciones de su excarcelación
Siguen sin estar claras podrá salir de
Irán o será sometida al resto
domiciliario el comité que la apoya no
se refiere al respecto
especialista en chismo y Campos
revolucionario la investigadora Franco
iraní fue detenida en 2019 y condenada 5
años de cárcel por atentar contra la
seguridad nacional
una acusación que sus familiares y el
gobierno francés siguen engando
tajantemente
atraerán se le acusa de usar Los Rehenes
como forma de chantaje aún quedan otros
seis franceses detenidos en Irán
la organización quedó se denuncia estas
detenciones arbitrarias y exige su
Liberación inmediata